Okay, Ariel says, why do you not touch the ones that have CPC as NA?
So the reason why real quick on that, Ariel, is because typically with CPC,
think about it, right?
Supply and demand.
So if the cost per click is zero, that means there's nobody else bidding on it, right?
There's no marketers.
There's no business owners.
There's no one else that's wanting to pay for those ads,
which I can therefore infer that it's worth nothing, right?
So for example, you're going to have a keyword like
cheap concrete companies in Newport, whatever, right?
That CPC is zero.
Why? Because no one cares about it.
So if you want to go like those CPCs,
the reason why is because it's typically it's a waste of time, right?
There's no volume.
It says there's volume, but it's not worth anything.
So if you want to go test it out, cool.
And there's probably like a couple situations where, yeah, it's going to work.
But I'm just using my intuition of saying, okay, there's CPC that's zero,
which means nobody cares enough to pay for it,
which means there's like one of many things, right?
There's too much supply and not enough demand or vice versa.
So that's why, okay?
Hope that makes sense.